[Music]  Mariah Carey really got into the  Valentine's Day mood what prompted that  mutation a moment how could you not  check out these pictures of the elusive  chanteuse that sexing it up in a bathtub  filled with balloons and surrounded by  candy oh and please note her bra it's  covered in Hershey's kisses oh my gosh  look at that sprays manager Stella  Buckner cop's daughter Mishka made the  bra she also took the pics and directed  the shoot the now 13 year old was  featured on Mariah's world as the  singer's social media manager  twelve-year-old makes the best social  media manager because a 12 year old is  who were appealing to all the kids do  all day is surf the web they know better  than we do let's not kid ourselves  [Music]